[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in chris sims pro football
talk live co-host nbc sunday night
football analyst did you ever get fined
for a uniform violation chris
yeah i did um i'm not showing two not
showing enough
black on the socks or no no showing too
much black on the socks for
you know the tampa bay buccaneers of
course you know like you know sometimes
you want it it's supposed to be the the
right proportion of white and black so
i
like the way all the black looked and it
would make it you know predominantly
black but you know you had to try to
trick the uniform guy to a degree to
make that happen but how are you told
that you're in violation well like first
off they're going to check you in
warm-ups and then they're going to come
through the locker room
after warm-ups maybe 10 to 15 minutes
before you go out there to the game and
they're gonna walk around and go hey
number two so you don't have enough
white in your socks hey number 32 you
know tuck your jersey in hey blah blah
blah your cleats are in violation and
they let you know but what guys do to
try to skirt that is if you go well what
i did i would go out to warm-ups very
proper and then i'd start the game and
i'd go ah they didn't warn me so they
can't find me yet and now i got my socks
changed and i looked a little different
but even doing that at halftime they
were gonna come tell you again they were
gonna get you but i don't know who i i
heard there to to to whoever it was i
don't know if it was fritzy or whatever
um
i do find the rule a little inconsistent
at times like like there's i could find
70 guys that i watched on film this past
week that had jerseys untucked they
weren't fine but for some reason cd lam
was and i don't i don't understand that
with the nfl at times all right let's
start with odell beckham jr
what team is the right fit not
necessarily where he goes but what what
is the best place for him to go
well
that it that it's a tough one i mean
i
i think i look at it and you know of
course you got the saints the chiefs
the patriots the packers those four
teams involved they all have little
different nuances as far as why i think
they're best all right so it's a hard
one for me to answer like hey the chiefs
they certainly need them it can't just
be tyree kill and kelsey but their
offense is struggling and mahomes is
struggling right now i mean plain and
simple i mean he's struggling you know
green bay you know they're they're not
the type of offense where
it's like the most diverse passing
offense in the world it's devante adams
devante adams devonte adams and not
necessarily always the scheme that leads
them there so i don't know can they find
a way to like you know infuse odell
beckham jr into that offense i think
they could i'd like to see that i do
think they need another guy if they want
to win the super bowl um but as far as
just like
maybe you know
you know what do i want to say jump
starting your career again and going to
places where you know it's a true
like proven
fact that they can get you the ball
that's where i go to the saints and the
patriots yeah but he doesn't trust
trevor simeon
well that's i and that's where that's
where that's why it's like hard for me
to give one here and that's why i want
to give a little context you're right
the trevor simeon thing is not that
appealing but sean payton knowing how to
get the ball to a guy all the time is
very appealing and he i would argue
maybe he's the best in football at doing
it maybe you know even before michael
thomas they could feature guys that way
and here's the other reason i would just
say the saints too because there could
be a little bit of a long play there as
well you know i think the michael thomas
uh saints relationship is over from
everything i know and i don't expect to
see him back in uniform there ever again
and he could be that guy for that
offense and i would think the saints are
going to be a major player for one of
these quarterbacks that's on the market
next year so they could be good for the
future that's what i would argue and
that's the same thing with new england
they know how to get the guys the ball
they can orchestrate offense around that
and then you have a future there to
build with with mac jones and be the guy
so
that that's my answer i know i kind of
copped out and didn't give you one place
but they all have some positives and
they all have some negatives to me and i
think that's why he's probably taken a
little time to try to figure this out
but there's a team that you've already
you mentioned before you even came on
the air i think you tweeted and it's
buffalo yeah because buffalo if if odell
beckham's big picture is being on a
winning team
well buffalo probably has the best
chance to go to the super bowl
and
you put him opposite stefan diggs you
got josh allen and you might have some
magic there i just i don't know if he
wants to go to buffalo but if you want
to go and win
that might be the place where you can go
and extend your career at least through
the postseason longer than any other
place
agreed he's got to be careful here you
know hey legacy's on the line he's got a
perception about him around the league
you know there's certain some people
that don't want anything to do with them
and you know again he's he's been a guy
that just hasn't got a lot of
opportunities he's athletically looked
still really good but the analogy i use
all the time is like you know if golden
state didn't throw the ball to steph
curry until the fourth quarter i'm sorry
he's not going to be the same steph
curry he's not just going to knock down
threes all over the place and odell
beckham jr the last two years has gone
through such long periods of time where
he's open a lot wait
you're blaming the brown scheme
i definitely to a degree the scheme and
baker mayfield would be the two things i
don't know what there was there there's
something there but i've broken this
down on my unbuttoned podcast a bunch
where i've shown
a long list of plays to go wait i know
this play i know how you're supposed to
read it and odell's wide open and i
don't understand why the ball didn't go
there so you know there's a little of
everything there that happened in
cleveland and cleveland's past game is
to me without the run game being success
successful is a little underwhelming but
like getting back to the bills you know
the only reason i didn't say them that's
the one that makes the most sense to me
but i just haven't heard any rumors or
anything substantial to think it's going
there but you hit it exactly right you
know their defense is super bowl-ish
they have no run game and right now it's
just josh allen and stefan diggs make
magic for us every week and they do need
another guy in my opinion if they think
they're going to march through the afc
playoffs and get to the super bowl
and that's that would be the one place
if i was talking to odell beckham jr and
i was talking to teams in the leagues
i'd go get that done that one seems to
make the most sense we had mike
tannenbaum on yesterday former front
office executive and i asked him about
baker mayfield would you sign him up
long term and he said no
he said right now he's the third best
quarterback in his own division
and he's going to cost you too much and
he's maybe the sixth seventh best
quarterback in the afc
which i don't even know if he's that
even though he is having a good year if
you look at his numbers he's having a
good year in fairness to him but you
know you can't get that sweet spot of 38
or 28 to 30 million dollars which maybe
you want him there but then i don't want
to pay him 40 to 45 million
like that to me is exactly it i mean
i i would sign up odell beckham jr i
mean how dublic baker mayfield long term
but it's going to have to be
on a term that makes sense for the
cleveland browns i think that's what i
would do you know again like
i you know baker's good it never happens
that way chris where uh well the the nfl
then a lot of people are going to have
to start dealing with carson wentz and
jared goff situations if they're going
to continue down this yeah and then
they're going to have to hear guys like
me tell them how stupid they are for
doing it you know so that's where like
they're not quarterback dependent their
team is built around the run game he's
not one of the 10 best quarterbacks in
football he's still very good but i
don't look at him as top 10 quarterback
we know it's kind of been up and down to
a degree so from that standpoint yes you
know i would sign them up but i wouldn't
give them 38 or 40 million dollars a
year absolutely not and the other thing
i say because i've had people ask me
this too i want to just go you know like
if you offered him 30 million or 28
million which is pretty good you know
money of course we know in the real
world and football quarterback money
that's kind of average all right but at
the same time what i've even i've had
these conversations with some people
around the nfl i just want to go well
who do you think's going to be like
knocking down the door going we got to
get baker mayfield to our team and we're
going to give them 40 something million
dollars because it's gonna change our
team no i don't think that's the
you know the perception or the reality
around that situation he's not aaron
rodgers or josh allen or russell wilson
or one of those guys or uh so that's
where you know that would be my my
stance on that uh halfway point of the
season your mvp is
[Music]
well it's not going to look good like
after last week i i i like before the
week started last week i said matthew
stafford matthew stafford be the guy i
would pick i mean you know first off i
think the success there has happened way
quicker than we anticipated he's changed
their football team you know
they got some injuries at the running
back position they're not as special
that way and now we don't have to go
like whoa if they can't run and don't
have bootlegs what are they going to do
in this week how are they going to
manage the game i hope the defense can
be phenomenal so to me he's changed the
perception of them throughout the whole
league let alone the nfc and i know it's
bad timing because he doesn't look great
but i you know to me i would go there
and of course i'm a little i guess
biased because everybody's crapped on
him so long in detroit he's horrible
he's horrible he's horrible so now he
must be great i guess that's that's
where i just i want to fight back
against that narrative but of course
kyla murray lamar
tom brady i think those are probably the
other three guys i look there like you
know nipping at his heels chris sims pro
football talk live co-host and
contributor to nbc sunday night football
the taunting penalty the other night
with tony corenti the uh the official
you had a run in with him when you were
playing which i found really interesting
explain that to the audience
sure you know first i did not agree with
that call i don't think that's why that
rule was put in place because of staring
at the sideline from 30 yards away sorry
that's just not what it was there for
it's not the video the nfl showed us
before the year to explain it you know
that's not it's not they're going you
know outside the lines on that but yes i
had a game in it was san francisco 2005
and
got hit really late you know after a
play i mean like maybe as late as i ever
was hitting my nfl career and nothing
was called and i kind of looked back at
him and i just as i was running i went
what the hell that was a late hit that's
like all i said ran off the field and
now as i you know you come back on the
next drive it's commercial break right
the referee usually gives you some
warnings about like when he's going to
blow the whistle and start the clock so
it happened once i'm kind of sitting
around and gruden's talking to my ear
and i'm looking at him and the guys are
talking to the huddle and he just blows
the whistle and i turn around i'm like
oh my gosh all right hey west right slot
72 z bingo use split all right it goes
on we have a timeout or something like
maybe a minute or two later and the same
thing happens and it happened i believe
three different times until i finally
went up to him to the next commercial
break and i said
why aren't you giving me a warning can i
get a warning before we come back from
break here that's kind of standard
protocol they kind of look at you and go
hey get your guys ready call your play
i'm going to blow the whistle that's
kind of how it goes every team every ref
every game all year and he looked at me
and he said are you going to apologize
for what you said earlier
and
i mean the competitor
wanted to be like would you get the hell
out of my face and i'd like to like
really say some four-letter words to you
but i didn't want to be ripped off by
him for the rest of the game and not him
call other penalties so i went i'm sorry
about that and then he said okay i'll
give you your warnings back
and i just to me that he's always
bothered me there's a lot of talk like
that around him you heard brian greasy
even during the telecast say he had his
run-ins with you know tony curranti a
lot of people have do you think he gets
a little personal do you think he
made contact
on purpose monday night cashless marsh
it i
i i just it appears that way i mean it
appears that way the whole thing is
weird you know as i've argued on the
show like i'm all for this rule i've
i've been one that's defended it because
i am a behind the like wait these are
role models the kids watch this and like
the aspect of what we wanted out of the
game was like the 40-yard run down the
sidelines and the defender makes a
tackle 40 yards down the field and he
gets up and he stands over him like yeah
i tackled you i know you almost got a
touchdown but i tackled you or you know
the receiver who catches a three yard
route and now the db tackle he stands
over him and puts his man junk in his
face like look i dominated you for three
yards oh my gosh that's gotta go like
that i'm all for that this is not what
the rules for i mean again and you know
like i said on pft with four how do you
know he wasn't looking at his mom in the
second row and just going like look at
me mom i mean to me that was just like
uh unnecessary and that's where common
sense has been lost by the referees in
the nfl in my opinion yeah but the nfl
didn't take any action against tony
corenti and to me of course
it's almost like he was trying to draw a
charge like come on and then he throws
the flag as soon as contact is made that
he
yes
you can throw the flag for taunting i
had no problem with that but you throw
it a couple of seconds earlier when the
taunting actually happens i had a real
problem with that and you know what he's
not gonna be disciplined by the nfl
they're gonna be like of course let's
just move on get into the weekend
everybody will forget about this hey
right that's right uh the nfl's never
made a mistake ever in the history of
their lives they've never made a mistake
right now they can still come after you
they come after your benefits
yeah you're right they could
hey great to talk to you as always chris
thank you have a great weekend
thanks man hey tell those idiots i said
hi hey idiots chris says uh hi
hi
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host